من المعروف ان التدخين يشكل خطرا على
النساء اثناء الحمل فدراسه جديده ركزت على
بعض البدائل للسجائر الالكترونيه
التقليديه يتبين انها لا تخلو من الاخطار
بعث علماء بتحذير عاجل النساء الحوامل
بخصوص بعض نكهات السيجاره الالكترونيه
البيت لافتين الى انها تزيد بمقدار
الضعفين خطر وقوع الاجهاض توصل العلماء من
خلال دراسه اجروها تم نشرها في دوريه الطب
الوقائي لان النساء اللواتي يدخلن
السيجاره الالكترونيه ذات طعمي النعناع
ومركب المنثول يواجهن خطر فقدان الاجنه في
احشائهن اكثر من غيرهن
[موسيقى]
يعني مثلا عندك الفي بول سجاير
الالكترونيه والايكوس وكل هدول صاروا بديل
عن السيجاره العاديه انه هي جديده على
السوق فبالتالي احنا ما بنعرف شو
تداعياتها في المستقبل والناس يفكروها اقل
خطوره من السيجاره العاديه ايش رايكم يسعد
صباحك صباح الخير
يعني هي هن بقولوا زي كليم بدعوا بانه
فيها 90 او 99% سموم اقل من السيجاره
العاديه بس زي ما قلتي نادين لسه الموضوع
جديد منعمل عليه دراسات كافيه وما صار وقت
كافي يعني الناس عم تستعملها لحتى يبين
مدارها يعني حتى بيقولوا انه لو السيجاره
العاديه مدارها على الجهاز التنفسي مثلا
لكن قد تكون السيجاره الالكترونيه مدارها
على جهاز اعصاب مثلا اعصاب الجسم او اي
امور اخرى لانه في منظمات الصحه العالميه
كذا مره حذرت من السجائر الالكترونيه
والدراسه الحديثه تحذر من سموم قد تسببها
تفضلي
كبيره نبطل ندخن احسن كله اريح